you grow up in this country you go to
public school you may learn about
eminent domain but until you're in the
crosshairs of the government you don't
understand how it really works they
invoke it and they take your land and
they do what they want we have spent the
last 16 years
revegetating returning to a native
landscape in both cultivated gardens and
wild state Mariana Trevino Wright is the
director of the national butterfly
center which is located near the US
border with Mexico and is home to the
largest concentration of butterflies in
North America this is the best place in
North America to observe butterflies and
to enjoy them owned and operated by the
North American butterfly association or
naba this 100 acre private wildlife
refuge is part of the Rio Grande Valley
conservation corridor where the last
flora and fauna native to the region are
preserved as pollinators of local plants
the butterflies are vital to the valleys
ecosystem we need our native plants we
need our butterflies and that's what
naba is all about
[Applause]
[Music]
the butterfly center is directly in the
path of Donald Trump's border wall a
project that's already moving forward
here in the Rio Grande Valley in the
2018 omnibus spending bill Congress
authorized one component of the project
a 33 mile section of fencing running
through the valley the dividing
structure will be built on top of a
levee that runs through the butterfly
center the levee has an easement that
allows the government to add fencing
without permission from the surrounding
landowners they call it levee fence to
exploit language in the easement that
they think makes it legal for them to
install an immigration barrier in the
levee easement 70% of the butterfly
centers land is on the river side of the
levee so it's still on the US side of
the border but the placement of the new
wall will make that property contiguous
with Mexico and difficult for Wright and
her staff to access and the border wall
is doing what
general Santa Hana could not do 150
years ago he couldn't push the border of
Mexico north of the Rio Grande River and
that is what the border wall is doing
the government's is also planning to
clear up to 200 yards on one side of the
levee to establish a control zone for
monitoring illegal entrance and it's
prepared to seize that land using
eminent domain you grew up in this
country you go to public school you may
learn about eminent domain but until
you're in the crosshairs of the
government you don't understand how it
really works they invoke it and they
take your land and they do what they
want but naty's not the only one
threatened by eminent domain rayon
saldua is descended from Spanish
settlers who in the 1700s were awarded
land grants in the valley totaling about
18,000 acres out of those 18,000 acres
now we probably have no more than 150
acres you know
so that's a lot of land to lose you know
and and here they come again with his
border wall on Sal duas first cousin
Fred Cavazos and Fred's sister Eloisa
Cavazos both live on a portion of the
family's property that will be cut into
the house where the Cavazos has lived
will end up on the US side of the wall
but much of their land and rental
properties fall on the Mexican side
making them so difficult to access
they'll likely become worthless building
the 200-yard control zone will mean
leveling the livestock pens and
additional rental properties belonging
to the Cavazos family this lab would
lose about ten acres and two barns and
three houses so when they asked me can
you help me cousin I say yes I I got
ties to this land too just like you do
this this is our grandmother's land and
Sal do is expecting the government to
make an offer to buy his cousin's land
but if the family declines the
government can move to take it any way
through eminent domain every time we
turn around somebody start trying to
take land from us and I said well this
for the good of the community what about
our own good it'll be who's compensating
us for for all this land that we're
losing this is enough we're gonna fight
it might be a losing battle but we still
little fight it but fighting could
backfire on the Cavazos family and the
valley landowners in 2008 when the Bush
administration was building an
immigration barrier in the neighboring
town of Brownsville the Department of
Homeland Security exploited loopholes in
the law meant to protect property owners
and in each case invoked a so called
declaration of taking which is a way to
expedite the eminent domain process
today landowners are still fighting for
what they consider just compensation for
the land they lost a decade ago there
are still 90 lawsuits open now because
their land was taken with no
compensation
90 lawsuits still open from almost ten
years ago and that's what will happen
again now further strengthening the
power of the executive branch to seize
land in the Rio Grande Valley is the
Real ID Act signed by George W Bush in
2005 as part of the administration's war
on terror it allows the government to
waive almost any law impeding the
construction of barriers and roads for
securing the border and there are 37
laws in the Real ID Act that the federal
government waives for border wall
construction they get to bulldoze tribal
lands grave sites historical landmarks
religious sites they do not have to
abide by the Clean Air Act or the Clean
Water Act the government has exempted
itself from all of the laws that govern
our country they've said they don't
apply to us for this purpose one
historic landmark that is no longer
protected thanks to the Real ID Act is
La Loma - chapel built in 1865 it sits
on a plot of land that will be
incorporated into the control zone the
city of Mission Texas is named for this
old mission on the banks of the Rio
Grande River it is a chapel that is in
use every day all day by members of our
community Nass is still given there this
is where we worship it as children this
is where my parents worship this is
where my grandparents worship this is
where my great-grandparents worship so
it's got a lot of significance for us
you know and we hate to lose this we
would hate to lose it
construction on the project hasn't
started yet but Customs and Border
Protection are a constant presence in
the area federal immigration law gives
the agency the authority to search and
patrol private property within 25 miles
of the border without obtaining a
warrant 24 hours a day
we are occupied by border patrol both
physically and virtually they drag tires
they have drones and helicopters they
have agents on foot on bicycle on dirt
bike on
on four-wheeler and SUV on boat on our
shores every kind of presence you can
imagine then they have planted
motion-activated sensors on our property
they have installed 24-hour video
surveillance our property probably the
Border Patrol here is about maybe three
or four times what it was even five
years ago so this border is pretty much
militarized the government however does
not have the authority at this point to
enter an alter private property in
preparation for the border wall but
treviño right says she encountered a
group of government contractors on the
butterfly centers property clearing
foliage that had been planted to host
butterflies and I was like what are you
guys doing here and they're like well
we're clear in this land I said my land
and the guide the young guy with the
orange vest and the safety goggles and
everything goes I think I should call my
supervisor and I said I think you should
do that too a few days later Manuel
Padilla the chief border patrol agent
for the Rio Grande Valley paid the
butterfly center a visit he showed up
unannounced with no appointment in plain
clothes and his attache and a uniformed
agent Padilla presented plans for the
border wall to treviño right and
according to her account
he said the contractors would be back
this time accompanied by a green
uniformed presence and so I asked him
about that later do I understand you
correctly that you are sending armed
federal agents onto private property to
protect your contractors naba decided to
take legal action suing the Department
of Homeland Security and Customs and
Border Protection part of our lawsuit is
that Patrol the definition of what is
patrolling
and do they really have the ability to
occupy our land our land according to
Border Patrol is theirs to do with as
they please after the lawsuit was filed
Border Patrol sent a form letter to
every property owner in the area asking
them for 18 months of irrevocable access
so the agency can survey the land to
prepare for construction many owners
including naba and the Cavazos family
refused to sign and I just got word this
week that the government has moved to
dismiss our lawsuit these issues will be
sorted out in court but regardless of
the outcome for the property owners of
the Rio Grande Valley the long-term
outlook is bleak they're literally
pulling the rug out from under our
community in terms of economic stability
jobs tax revenue and with nothing
to replace any of that
[Music]